Vsauce Kevin here fighting an inflatable
dragon with a plastic sword which is all
you can do with a dragon their fairy
tale foes in the West but for some
reason the dragon image has existed all
over the world since the dawn of
civilization so is the dragon just a
fantasy cliche or does it help explain
our evolution embody our oldest fears
and unite all of humanity and when old
maps marked unexplored territories with
here be dragons well where be dragons
everywhere South America Central America
North America Europe Asia Africa and
Australia the dragon is a universal
ancient concept long before legends of
English Knights besting maiden devouring
fire-breathing dragons the Aztec
worshipped Quetzalcoatl a feathered
serpent sky dragon god of wisdom and
life and the ancient Greek serpent
dragon Laden was trusted with guarding
immortality granting golden apples until
he was defeated by the demigod Heracles
lot in like many dragons was very snaky
wait why are dragons and snakes so
closely related to get to our
imaginations ultimate predator we have
to start with the first persistent
predator of our evolution molecular
phylogenetic estate organisms date like
time not date like
you know believe that our earliest
placental mammal ancestors began
flourishing within 400,000 years of
dinosaur extinction about 65 and a half
million years ago but snakes basically
as we know them today were around 100
million years ago they had about 20
million years of alone time eating
placental mammals before predatory Birds
joined the party and at another 2
million years before the first
carnivorous mammals evolved snakes had
been eating every iteration of our
evolving ancestors for millions of years
so by the time Homo sapiens evolved and
developed language we were talking about
our oldest arch enemy snakes and was
considered the oldest known great piece
of literature mesopotamias epic of
gilgamesh Gilgamesh's immortality is
stolen by a snake a snake makes him
mortal the Abrahamic origin story says
that a serpent convinced Eve to eat
forbidden fruit from the tree of
knowledge of good and evil by promising
that her eyes would be opened she and
Adam were subsequently banished from an
immortal paradise but the mortal threat
of snakes might have literally helped
our eyes the snake detection hypothesis
suggests that visual systems of primates
evolved to detect dangerous animals
primarily venomous snakes in the fruit
the tree and the serpent anthropologists
Linda's Bell explains the hypothesis
like this snakes evolved to be difficult
to see and morally dangerous they coiled
their camouflaged bodies and remain
motionless until they attack surviving
the peril of snakes for millions of
years required selective pressure
favoring primates specialized visual
systems and compared to other mammals
the pulvinar region of the brain which
helps visually detect relevant objects
is
disproportionately large in primates and
humans studies from different
international labs have detailed the
ability of humans enhanced visual relay
system to recognize snakes and this site
is preconscious blind site which lets
even those with cortical blindness
respond to visual stimuli without
knowingly perceiving it allows us to
detect snakes and react without being
consciously aware of them basically we
can notice and react to a snake without
having to think there is a snake I'd
better watch out or like Explorer Percy
Fawcett wrote about dodging the attack
of a Bushmaster I had not seen it until
it flashed between my legs but the inner
man if I can call it that not only saw
it in time but judged its striking
height and distance exactly and issued
commands to the body accordingly
Fawcett's inner man was confirmed by a
1993 study on conditioned electrodermal
responses to masked fear relevant
stimuli not very catchy consistent with
the hypothesis the lemurs of Madagascar
an early branch of primates living on an
isolated island off the coast of Africa
with no venomous snakes do not fear
snakes and have poor vision armed with
the vision to detect them we quickly
learn to fear snakes Oh fiddy Oh phobia
or a fear of snakes is one of the most
common and intense phobias in the world
in the dragons of Eden Carl Sagan notes
dream studies in which almost half of
the people surveyed reported dreams
about snakes and while modern
psychologists studies show neither human
infants nor monkeys raised in captivity
inherently fear snakes studies of fear
Association showed both are prepared to
learn lab monkeys showing no initial
fear response were conditioned to fear
live as well as toys snakes after
viewing videos of wild monkeys
demonstrating a fear response to snakes
researchers were unable to condition the
monkeys to fear non-threatening stimuli
like flowers or toy rabbits
we notice and fear snakes as part of a
coevolution arms race for survival that
eventually led us to telling legendary
stories of our origins amongst serpents
skeptics of the snake detection
hypothesis would like to see more data
like studies done with primates reacting
not to just snakes but to other primate
predators like leopards and eagles and
in any case dragons don't just look like
snakes
dragons have legs they can fly and they
have a mouth full of ferocious sharp
teeth dragons are more like a snake
mixed with a leopard and an eagle the
three predators monkeys are screaming
about when anthropologist David Jones
studied howler monkeys he noticed they
used three distinct alarm signals that
lead to specific instinctive safety
actions one call alerts the group to a
snake and they stand up on their hind
legs to look at the ground and then
climb to safety in the tops of trees
another call identifies a hunting bird
or Raptor and monkeys abandon the trees
hit the ground and take cover in bushes
finally a call for a leopard or large
carnivorous causes them to run into the
trees and out onto the thinnest branches
that can't support heavier meat-eating
mammals in an instinct for dragons Jones
writes that the dragon is a composite
creature of the three major predators of
primates serpent carnivore and Raptor he
believes combining them into one monster
is a natural indexing mechanism
performed by the brain to consolidate a
message that message is to recognise
beware and honor what Georgia's makar
called in her 1968 book the beasts of
never the oldest the first in the most
basic monster McHarg was right the epic
of gilgamesh not only mentions dragons
but features the demigod baba whose
dragon like characteristics included the
head of a lion the claws of a vulture a
body covered in thorny scales and a tail
that ended in
snakes head also a phallus that ended in
a snake's head phallus means winner
conquering or harnessing the power of
this symbol of nature's chaos granted
the hero the power to create order
Chinese emperors are said to be
descended from dragons and adorns their
kingdoms with dragon imagery in the east
civilizations were created with the
blessing of dragons in the west
civilizations drew power from tales of
defeating them but something weird
happened to dragons in Western culture
of the last hundred years these
manifestations of evil that needed to be
vanquished to secure our future became
friends with our future dragons became
playmates for children The Reluctant
dragon written by Kenneth Grahame in
1898 was the first popular Western story
in which a dragon is a sympathetic
character it tells the tale of a
bookworm child who befriends and defends
a peaceful poetry loving dragon from the
stubborn ideological local villagers who
believe all dragons must be destroyed as
tradition demands the valiant dragon
slayer of legend st. george is summoned
to kill the dragon
but the child successfully convinces the
knight to spare his harmless friend to
appease the bloodthirsty villagers they
stage a fake battle in which George
innocently pierces a fold of skin on the
Dragons neck George then parades the
dragon through town and declares he is
no longer a threat the knight the child
and the dragon walk away peacefully
hand-in-hand into the night Peter Green
wrote in a 1959 biography of Kenneth
Grahame and he grew up in the
countryside of Berkshire during a time
so simple kids entertained themselves by
playing games like push the heavy log as
an adult Graham was reluctantly forced
into banking in the booming city of
London after being unable to afford his
dream of going to Oxford University at
the height of uncontrolled development
of manufacturing during the
revolution the whimsy and serenity of
Graham's rural youth contrasted starkly
with the rigid responsibilities of
begging in polluted urban 19th century
London The Reluctant dragon represents
the inner turmoil Graham felt between
his creative artistic self the dragon
and his dutiful banker self embodied by
the fable Dragon Slayer st. George in
the end the night the child and the
dragon make peace with one another at a
time when Graham reconciled with his own
inner struggle between being an artist
and being a prominent member of the
establishment the first friendly dragons
story is a negotiation between the rigid
control of modern humanity and the
anarchist entropy of nature brokered by
the precocious innocence of adolescence
the dawn of modern science and human
advancement required a compromise
between our past and our future we
became friends with an enemy we had
fought for time immemorial an enemy who
represents time immemorial the aura
Boris a serpent or dragon eating its own
tail symbolizes the infinite cycle of
nature creation from destruction a
fundamental truth recorded by the
earliest civilizations life and death
eternal
[Music]
today we don't need dragons not like we
used to the millions year war is over
and we're still here living and
breathing the fire of curiosity and
courage instinctively exploring the
deepest darkest depths of the unknown
and overcoming the impossibly powerful
enemy guarding the most valuable
treasure imaginable using our minds to
detect problems and invent ways to
conquer challenges it's how we evolved
but into what
philosopher Friedrich Nietzsche warned
he who fights too long against dragons
becomes a dragon himself
devoid of the monsters that strengthen
us for this moment left with the power
to decide mi the night
am i the child
or mi the dragon
and as always thanks for watching
you
you
[Music]
you